[Music]
hey everyone it's Wednesday 11:00 a.m.
Pacific in San Francisco California so
you know what time it is it's time for
the lobby games last weekly video game
hangout I'm Mike McCarty here as always
with reviews editor Peter Brown hello
producer Robert Hamme Laurie hi and
editor Kelly plaguey hello we have a
full show ahead of us as always I'm in
the twitch and youtube chats so if you
have any questions throw them in there I
use the word microtransactions in a
tweet asking for questions so naturally
I got like 12 of them through Twitter
before the show we'll get into those
later on we're gonna talk about shadow
for microtransactions 4 to 7 and
battlefront to beta
Rob you spent a lot of time with
battlefront to beta we're gonna talk
more about that in general maybe what
hopefully can change by November you've
got some thoughts on that Kelly you have
you just reviewed a hat in time then the
3d platformer we talked about it last
week but any final thoughts before I get
into some news it's recommended it's
very cute I would recommend it if you're
into 3d platformers it's a lot of people
were joking that it's like what we
wanted ukulele to be and I don't know if
I would take it that far but I enjoyed
it a lot
cool yeah you're full reviews up on
GameSpot so people can go check that out
if 3d platformers are your jam otherwise
we're gonna be talking some Star Wars
the movie trailer for the last Jedi in
general I might touch on Blade Runner
but I don't wanna spoil any of that
because that's we won't talk too much
I'm gonna spoil it for me live like
whispering into my yeah
yeah no I mean it's like seriously when
the segment sure GT sport Pete them
playing that demo a big-ass demo a big
demo big-ass demo don't worry we're also
gonna be talking work evil within to
we're gonna save til next week so
Bethesda actually was gracious enough to
send out review copies earlier than like
a day before which was their new policy
for a while yeah I'm not sure what the
deal is with evil didn't - oh well I
don't even know if it's just this game
maybe they're rethinking things in
general but yeah
we'll get into that mainly next week but
I will touch on it cuz overall thoughts
on that game are actually very positive
especially around our office and I'm
kind of seeing around Twitter and
whatnot
and yeah we have a giveaway that's been
running all week you might already have
heard about it it's the shadow
sorry not shadow of word evil within two
Xbox one and ps4 copies we're giving out
and then also on Friday the grand prize
two people will win either an Xbox one s
console with the evil within two skin or
the ps4 evil then two skin you can see
both of those right here if you're
watching this second I thought he was
pulling the gun himself at the end I
wouldn't be surprised that would fit
with this game Shiva who runs or Twitter
will be in the twitch chat putting the
link on for the GameSpot article you can
go there and we're picking when five
winners everyday for the games and then
again Friday will be the grand prize for
one of these two the ps4 pro or the xbox
one else with said skin my skin yeah
[Laughter]
skins if you are the grand prize winners
so look forward to that overwatch the
Halloween event is live we did a loot
crate unboxing speaking of how to do
loot crate's correctly I would say
overwatch got some Halloween skins and
really all that matters is za Ria's
apologies to a jean-luc fer because I
didn't really tell him that he should be
prepared for this uh but there's there's
some good skins but Joey was nice enough
to point out that za Ria's new 80s
obviously they're all costumes but she's
got an eighty skin also that right there
looks like Deckard's gun from Blade
Runner as it's supposed to which she was
at a Blade Runner costume that I know
all over the pirate costume oh no here
we go yeah some McCree a lot of good
skins this is this is alive now it's on
PC and ps4 I would assume so you can go
check this out but yeah basically this
Ari has got this 80s like workout
costume with knee-high socks and her
gums pretty great too
so just go dragons so much dragon so
much was really good hopefully we see
her gun her cannon looks pretty dope can
see her guns right now yeah there it is
also what's what's his name's and yata
is like Cthulhu looking squid thing is
pretty cool too I've heard that's the
coolest one
I thought wrong you just saw the quote
it was that a lie he was a Viking but
like I immediately found of lost Vikings
if that was like oh it could be yeah
like I wonder house and I wonder how
similar that was nice callback Rob
[Music]
that's oh that's the dragon one you're
talking about well she looked like
wouldn't make her first second ray she's
you the guy yeah look at the guy in the
gun that's pretty gun is so good I mean
I found out yesterday that I can get
which mer seeks and missed which mercy
the first time so I am tempted to play
again but also yet Cthulhu this feet are
just like two tentacles oh so cool
alright Halloween I would we did a
stream right the normal Eric Tai Joey
unboxing stream unboxing loot crate's
stream we just pay like what 50 bucks
and then see what we get I didn't catch
it but that's usually what they do so
you can go check that out probably
archives on YouTube twitch if you want
to check that out get a closer look the
skins we also have galleries up if
you're interested otherwise just go play
it cuz that gave us a can still
phenomenal I can't wait to do that with
battlefield battlefront 2 and it comes
out you're really gets that
microtransactions chat aren't you before
we get there
iron banner is also alive in destiny -
mm-hm as opposed to the first game iron
banner does not take your weapons stats
and whatnot into account solid level
playing field correct yeah Ali you've
been playing this yeah it's some people
were a little disappointed because it's
kind of like for as far as PvP goes you
have quick play which is like the most
relaxed and there's competitive which
are more high-intensity boats and then
there's trials of the nine and then the
next level would be iron banner where
your power or light would come into
account but they changed at this time I
think that's part of destiny two's like
overall pushed towards making things
more accessible for all players I mean
it you do get different loot for doing
iron banner so there are reasons to do
it and it's kind of I think that I don't
remember which class it was but there's
it sort of looks like samurai ask so
yeah I'm going for that the Titan of
the warlocks looks kind of like medieval
tunic like chainmail almost yeah it's
even a good comparison
maybe like a Winterfell armor set from
game
Thrones I don't even watch tree watching
that it's weird because iron banner to
me aside from the loot like you
mentioned specifically Kali it was
always that kind of thing to actually
show like show off what I've earned yeah
if you worked really hard to get outside
of your aesthetics
yeah to get like a to max power which in
next power sounds so stupid
max light or whatever you want to call
it get that it's 3:05 in this game like
you get there and then that's your
opportunity to like really show off and
and that's your right that's um kind of
I think where some people are committed
a disappointment yeah someone who didn't
play destiny one I'm finding that
although I enjoy the opportunity to get
new loot it does feel like a missed
opportunity to offer what you guys are
talking about yeah that high level
reward for you know the best players
quote-unquote yeah actually you could
just enter with a very very low level
character never that matter power 11
[Music]
Savior your first term rest what I did
oh he put through him in the vault yes
don't like rap it out yeah it was yeah
it's like damaged it's like yeah alright
you can go check all this out on
GameSpot like I said this is also an
archived stream from wente was playing
we also will have I don't know Billy
Guides up for any that probably not for
iron banner we have like play your ass
off yeah rundowns of what it is and how
it works
I know I think I think it was Tewa
saying that he
we got for loot drops and two-word OOP
weapons and only one was an armored
piece yeah I've gotten I've turned it in
for like five packages now and I've only
gotten one piece of iron banner gear
well that's live if you want to play it
[Music]
before we get into the Star Wars trailer
because I know most people watching this
will kind of like to hear about that
I saw Blade Runner 2049 again like I was
looking up I was reading reviews
afterward and apparently a lot of movie
critics were saying this is like the
most adamant company has ever been
saying don't spoil anything so like if
you read reviews they're all super broad
and I can understand why I would say
especially if you've seen the first
movie but I skin absolutely loved this
movie I would highly suggest going to
see it Jared Leto is not my favorite
part but everything else is great Denis
Villeneuve is quickly becoming like and
already is an amazing director with
Sicario arrival this is just another you
know addition to his portfolio and I
highly recommend it even if you didn't
see the first one I it was it helps if
you've seen the first one but this is uh
this does new things as well this is
like one of the reviews I read as well I
was like say what you will about the
plot or like any issues you had with
this movie like you cannot argue like
its attention to each frame o it I would
wrap my frame off oh my god it's like
just like you cannot help but me just
blown away like throughout the entire
time it's and it's different it's it's
like one of the or it's not the most
like ambitious sci-fi I think I've ever
seen like in like our modern era of like
sci-fi blockbuster movies like it's
something completely different it's two
hours and 45 minutes which I just sounds
long and it it doesn't I think it
dragged maybe toward the end of like the
first hour maybe I'd midway through but
other than that it didn't feel that long
like I was there were scenes in this
movie that I for the first time in a
while when I saw this movie there were
scenes I didn't want to end they were so
good I was like oh I don't want to leave
the scene and that happened several
times
but yeah go check that out I highly
recommend it Rob did you see it last
night or something just hot you have to
go Friday okay yeah that movies great I
highly recommend this to everyone
Duff and also definitely avoid drinking
or like not booze but in general like oh
okay oh my god like kind of experience
did you have yeah I just I just had the
experts was like I have you know once
I'm thinking about it it's just worse
than like not enjoying the movie I'm so
frickin bad at that should be like a
group voting thing in a movie theater
where if like everyone pause sprinting
down thinking like okay this was pretty
boring I think yeah it's an amazing
movie bring a catheter if you need to go
see it it's well worth checking out
Star Wars last Jedi trailer drops during
Monday Night Football on ESPN the other
night I think overall positive thoughts
Rob you're super stoked Josh yeah you
guys were gum there are a lot of lot of
thoughts you know what's interesting is
like compared to you know it's what's I
think I don't know at this point I don't
want a spoilery any spoilers right like
no one wants that this is a long trailer
this is a long trailer but like I was
surprised compared to the other trailers
that oh by the way his hand has the same
blaster damage from Return of the Jedi
when he got shot on the con job as uh
what was it was I called that barrage
was it we call the barge barge yeah
desert skiff barrage anyway anyways
compared to other trailers like I I mean
I'm always in like the thread the
subreddits first Star Wars leaks and so
like that and like there wasn't that
much to pull from this like this movie
is still pretty unknown like we have you
know you could say like oh there's this
looks like a battle here there but from
the most part
like heavy-handed in this direction
right like the last there's notable
moments like this was one yeah this guy
I started crying when I saw I was I was
watching this for the first time last
night look in the background those dudes
are way too chill walking around if
there are battle if there are under
attack
there's right one later on in this
trailer okay the pork is really cool I'm
not a pork finger in bhakti walks walks
are great that's literally I think he's
cute I don't know
wait what okay I don't okay so there's
another shot later on we're a wooden ray
says like I need someone to show me my
place in all this and then it cuts to
the next shot and it's kylo holding his
hand and they make it look like it's the
same scene but we were talking about I
don't think it is yeah I really don't
think it is I think she's talking to
Luke on Achtung she's training on at
night she's even more so she's wearing
oh you can show it you cut early but the
lighting is very different in his in his
scene it's like flames falling but like
embers flying around in hers it's very
directional as far as the light like you
know her face is very much like as
shadow on the right side he's like
pretty evenly lit here we go
yeah hers looks like those look like
different shots or different locations
you pointed out like force awakens had a
lot of misdirection in the trailer as
well not just this like these trails I
guess it remains to be seen
yes you're right we don't know what if
there's planning the seed of
misdirection and it's all they just like
gave us that's you think my those guys
on Twitter right Adam driver and Ryan
just don't watch the trailer it's
spoilery yeah yeah I feel like you're
another major game / entertainment site
you can tweet saying that ryan johnson
said don't watch the trailer and take it
completely out of context and make it
seem like he said that when he didn't
but yeah it's he did not know well he
said he said I'm touring the trailers
great but if you want to go and
completely free maybe avoid it fire
someone else was on their Twitter
account said Ryan Johnson says
definitely don't watch the trailer
someone else asked him like who's very
talking to and he just said Luke yes
they were saying like good luck getting
ryan Johnson or Kathleen Kennedy to say
who the last Jedi is yes and then he
just responded says it's Luke
but yeah overall positive thoughts the
only thing I don't like was pose line
and I've been going off about this Star
Wars not been hammy though right but
this but this one didn't seem like the
fit poet wasn't like I there's cheesy
there's like I love you I know but
there's and then in the rogue one
trailer when what's-her-name jyn erso
was saying like there's the rebellion
right IRA Bell I actually like that line
because it it seemed like a little bit
defiant though was just like over I
thought rebel I thought that was around
different more cheesy than one I'm one
of those people who liked rogue one a
lot so yeah I can't really talk too much
about yeah you know those lines but
positive thoughts about Ryan Johnson's
episode eight coming out what December
15th yes everybody got I got 1:15 a.m.
tickets two of them yeah
I blacked out and just like okay got
Thursday night and then I got Sunday
night I was like well I'm gonna go
Friday Saturday then without seeing it
[Laughter]
was the last time you'll be able to get
it oh yeah good point
what's the what hour is the first
showing on Thursday that you got tickets
for Oh me it was like seven what's so
nice why is it 11
I'm Wow two hours behind you oh my god
the only every other seat I tried to get
I meant to get two tickets for my
girlfriend myself and all these seats
were just won like I could have gone
with her and we think I'd like a 7 8
p.m. showing and sat like a theater away
but I'm just like I'll wait just stay
off Twitter for that next five hours
yeah
I delete it from your phone for a little
bit mm-hmm it's it's absurd how quickly
those tickets went to overall positive
though pause the trailer mm-hmm was my
face hit me as much as that second force
awakens trailer but I don't think
anything ever well you think in the
third one the third one I really did
start tearing up when I saw Carrie
Fisher though oh yeah which is so like
she has to die in West Jedi right they
said she's not gonna be an episode nine
it's not true but she's not gonna be in
episode 9 correct and they thought they
confirmed that they're not gonna do any
CGI with her or have they already shot
scenes with her because I said they're
not gonna bring her back in CGI they
said that's a good point
they said so that could be well maybe
they they tried a lot of these movies
don't even exist maybe it's all mystery
maybe everything is made up nothing
matters just about like how the episode
9 will like not not like toss her out
completely like they will it'll it will
be tied in ok there's a rumor that like
no pilot will just blow her up in that
scene there was a rumor of these three
movies originally what I wanted was like
force awakens to be by han Solo
this one to be about Luke and the last
one be about Leia sorry that was like
that was an original yeah that was like
a big deal is what what people were
saying okay sorry my phone's just going
off
alright so popular people are mad cuz
we're not talking about games cuz we
don't like anything else besides games
so let's get to that yeah stardew valley
is on switch now as of last Tuesday I
believe stardew valley Tuesday was
lovers in a dangerous space-time which
I'm still trying to get people to play
with me one of the better maybe not
better one of the most like
underappreciated co-op games in the last
few years and it's inspired by the
turret scene with Han and Luke and a new
hope oh that's where I keep hearing
about that we should play that you could
play for player on one screen
we really yeah two or four I really want
to say how excited I am that you've been
tweeting about star D Valley yeah you
feel like you're converted I didn't
totally I drank the kool-aid finally I
didn't really do late
blue hair Mac oh so this is old footage
of Mary so I played on PC two years ago
when it came out was a 2015 or 2016
correct me I think it maybe was 16 last
year yes so I played it and I didn't
really get into it I felt like I was
doing something wrong and then more I
heard about it over the last year the
Morrow's excited played on switch a
because it was made I mean the switch is
perfect for it and it's one of the
perfect switch games I've been up till
like 3:00 a.m. the past three nights
playing it just because I'm laying in
bed yeah I'm gonna say like oh I'll go
I'll do some farming on Wednesdays when
the shops are closed I'll either go
mining or I'll go fishing fishing can be
hard in this game like I suck at it
fishing is tricky it's there's a lot of
things about the controls that I find
help like fishing I think was is was
harder for me on PC where I really
played it I tweeted about beating the
arcade game in the saloon journey of the
Prairie King that game is really hard oh
is it like a it's it's a twin stick
shooter so on PC it's extremely
difficult and doing any diagonal
shooting is pretty much impossible oh so
there's a lot of improvements there I
will say that the loading and saving
times are a little long so it even says
on the loading screen I don't maybe this
is the case on PC ps4 as well noise
which says this process can take a long
time yeah not like this process can take
a moment this process can take a long
time straight up says that finally it
dings and the green thing says progress
safe yeah and next day and it's it's a
little I wouldn't say it's frustrating
or even annoying it's just like that's
the one blemish on an otherwise like
ideal way to play this game so I'm not
it's not harming the experience for me
I'm so happy I can play this you know on
the train or in bed or you know I can
bring it with me which is what I wanted
originally when I played it on PC so I'm
very very happy about that
another minor thing that I had to look
up so why is Mary carrying this
blackberry
but another a minor thing is the menus I
would recommend going into the options
and changing the selection cursor to
like manual on the right analog stick
like a mouse cursor because if you just
try to use it like like a normal
controller menu interface trying to
think how to describe this rather than
if you just use the basic default tile
interface like scrolling or like
clicking to go left one square some of
the craftable items aren't like don't
register so you fire the furnace so i've
looked it up in people are saying yeah
it sucks but you just need to switch it
to the manual like mouse cursor and use
the right analog stick yeah and and
that's actually not very difficult to do
and you wouldn't have to use it that
often unless there was something that
you know you couldn't get on the
grafting menu so how are the touchscreen
controls though I don't think there's
they're implemented are they they're
implemented for text so like when I was
naming my town and my dog and stuff like
that I uses like this switch yeah it's
not like implemented into the integrated
into the game there's actually a Ballmer
house think about that yesterday because
for those menus that would be the
touchscreen would be Oh perfect yeah I
named my farmer Dwight and then my
farmers fruit farm and my dog is and
you're just gonna just have beets yeah
my chicken is Toby the HR rapid I'm so
that's that's perfect but I also made
him look like Dwight he's wearing a
mustard colored shirt brown pants and
they have a hairstyle from the front it
looks like him it's like the parted
bangs I'm coming from the side it's more
of a mullet either way I honestly like
for the first weekend so this past
weekend this is all I did was play this
game and then I finally beat it and when
you beat it you get a version of the you
get a arcade cabinet for your house so
now I can play it whenever I want
yeah oh she's not like that game well
what's the other game you need you need
a key to open it so you can't get it
right away playing a game within a game
is such a thing what's it called it's
funny because back in timesplitters to
organize your menu on your temporal
uplink which is the item that just has
your map and like heat signatures you
could go to it and play it was centipede
mm-hmm and I think there are two other
games I figured what they were but then
if you played homefront the revolution
last year or two years ago I never came
out you could play two levels from time
splitters
- it was all um I toss people I believe
don't forget animal crossing had NES
games in it that's I was gonna bring up
actually I played a lot of NES games on
the original Animal Crossing which was
my first introduction to those games
breath of the wild hedge shadow of
mordor in it games really I didn't get
that far in that game I wish I did oh
yeah especially after seeing Blade
Runner it kind of made me want to go
back to it danganronpa ii had a
tamagotchi thing in it but of course was
really twisted which are back now by the
way I know I saw a cute thing died what
is danganronpa and what are tamo Gucci's
is consumed my week and it's going
really well
my I would say my farm is profitable I
just love I don't know I never usually
got into games because I well maybe I
would like Animal Crossing now that I've
been liking stardew valley but I didn't
really like as far as maybe it was
because I don't know again it was ps4 I
didn't like playing this game in front
of a screen that way of like just
sitting there kind of I get it I get the
appeal now but it just feels so much
more tailor-made for the switch I mean I
I will say like going from Gamecube
Animal Crossing to wild world on DS I
could not go back to console Animal
Crossing and when city folk came out on
Wii I played maybe an hour and I was
like I'm not into this I think platform
can be a really big part of your
enjoyment of a game especially a game
like this and I will say like I've said
before stardew valley just does a really
good blend of you're managing a farm it
is a farm sim but you have you know the
relationship stuff you have the mines
and managing your time between those
different activities is just a really
strong part of this game I didn't even
there's a lot of like late-game stuff
that I didn't know existed in terms of
your relationships and stuff it's also
kind of interesting to see how you know
you the whole premise at the beginning
is you're leaving an office job because
your grandpa left the farm to you and he
said this could just be exactly what you
need but of course like when you want to
get really into it you run the danger of
just creating your own daily grind again
and not like connecting with people
right and that can become a problem
later in the game but still I don't
think they they don't like chastise you
for anything really I mean there's
definitely I think you can get more
enjoyment
if you are like fostering those
relationships with people I think that's
the point of the game
honestly when it comes down to it but
every in every other aspect it's great
about just letting you play how you want
it and I think that's the key thing here
I stopped worrying about what I was
doing correctly or incorrectly and I
just enjoyed it and yeah it's really
good at encouraging that which I yeah
it's like you said that's the point what
the hell is why is there fruit lying in
this cave
you can pick whether you want mushrooms
or fruit in your cave what do you mean
your cable also know you can't plant but
there's a cave on your farm and also I
know Mary would really wanted to marry
Sebastian and that's one of his favorite
gifts so she should totally go give it
to him in retro actively I would tell
her to do that sorry is that part of a
quest or will fruit to start growing
your cave randomly I forget how it
initiates but that you have an
opportunity to say I want bats in my
cave or I want mushrooms in my cave or
whatever the two options are and so one
of the options get you fruit and one
option gets you mushrooms cool um
depends on what you want and I don't
know who to marry and it's really
stressing me out
I like Abigail I think she's the one
purple hair is really brooding well see
ya I'm torn between the emo guy and the
scape Shane and Alex Sebastian and Sam
[Music]
[Laughter]
the football one is Alex he always says
aw we'll play catch tomorrow but then he
never does oh he told me uh that he
would play catch with me if I wasn't a
girl oh my god alex is such a star to
valley
he could have Haley as if enough people
haven't been recommending it I've gotten
on that bandwagon and I really like it
you have a switch and haven't played it
or if you have a switch and you haven't
and you put it on PC this is a great
time play it again if you don't have a
switch just get a switch cool
so that's starter Valley GT sport Pete
you play a little bit of it you had a
sizable demo they even kind of tinkering
around yeah
big ass nice how is it so far I like it
quite a bit Gran Turismo is
a bit of a strange racing game if you
just look at it as a racing game it's
it's a very simple very focused on being
like realistic and in many ways you can
tune like God you can tune your car in
just too many ways and I can really
understand like I'm not a Motorhead but
I have to imagine this is perfect for
someone that likes to you know tinker
with that stuff and you can also you
know dial it back and add some assists
so you can just have fun driving they
put a lot of attention to detail in the
cars the environments as well although
I'm I'm kind of mixed feelings on them
but I've only seen a few because the
demo doesn't have everything just yet
but one of the things that Gran Turismo
offers is sort of these these lessons
and it used to be a licence system where
you would have to earn your license with
various classes of cars and they'd take
you through baby steps and it sounds
boring like drive 100 meters and stop in
this little area it sounds very boring
on paper but when you do it especially
within the game that is so demanding
like this you feel like you slowly come
to grips with what it's asking of you
you know when you turn the assists off
so it's actually a really nice way to
sort of immerse yourself in the game bit
by bit and get better it's also the UI
in this series is always a mess yeah you
could say was about to man used to be a
mess looks like a level creator yeah
it's really rough you know it doesn't
take too long to really get get used to
it but it's it's not what I would call
great but one of the awesome things
about it's a track mode screen is as you
can see as I sort of like cycling
through footage and I forgot to give you
John Luke the proper footage right now
but ok so here you go once in a while
it'll show you like a car and give you a
year and then it will and then it'll
fade to a slide whereas like in 2008 Amy
Winehouse won the Grammy or like in 1976
the neutrino or the anti neutrino was
discovered like why and
around it but it's not relevant to the
car no neutrinos kami Winehouse drove a
Ferrari and so you kind of like sit here
and you almost like wait for these
things to pop up because they're so
ridiculous but you can also go into a
museum where it'll take you step by step
through the history of each car
manufacturer and then you can actually
like go down to the timeline beneath it
to see all of the oddities that are in
the game you know in terms of events
from the past it's really quirky stuff
like that but it adds like an unique air
to the game that you just don't get from
something like Forza that's it not to
say that like it has to be Gran Turismo
versus for its up but having spent some
of the weekend playing that to prepare
myself for this because I haven't really
been into racers in the past few years
four to seven I think has one of the the
least likable relationships like the
least likable dialogue with you as a
game and you as a player it has this
like weird stiffly animated you're like
racer who's always kind of like bobbing
up and down on the screen this narrator
like yeah you made the next step in your
career like you're about to rank up bud
like it's meanwhile this is just lame
two years ago the live-action cutscenes
was that burnout we'll get back to no it
was either speed yeah sorry okay so this
takes a very classy sort of like like I
feel like if Cosmo Yamauchi is a very
wealthy guy I have to assume he like got
himself into professional racing having
like no experience and takes it very
seriously but it's like funding a lot of
it all himself and I have the feeling
that like his mansion is sort of like
the spirit of Gran Turismo like where he
lives but there must always be like
piano playing and like Celine Dion walks
by at one point it's like strange
classiness that you're like yeah yeah
it's like I don't know why but like I
feel like I'm more sophisticated playing
this game than any other racing game
which has nothing to do with the racing
of it but the racing is also very
sophisticated and and complex and
nuanced and interesting because I was
asked me this the other day if you were
gonna like put it on a scale from arcade
to sim it would kind of be in the middle
oh well in the middle because you can
you can
have assists like Forza where you don't
even have to break you can just hold
down the accelerator and just power
through levels yeah
but that brings you to my next point so
Gran Turismo 6 which I did play that
game was littered with microtransactions
and the economy was skewed so that you
would have to race a stupid amount of
times to afford the cars you really
wanted or just pay $100 a real-world
currency to afford that car like
mind-bogglingly it was a poor decision
that ruin the experience of Gran Turismo
for me personally so coming to this it's
like they fixed a lot of that stuff I
haven't seen anything with
microtransactions there are two types of
currency but I'm earning them both and
they sort of feed into different market
places like one I used to buy cars from
the showroom you're the one I used to
buy like cosmetic stuff and special cars
that pop up and getting enough of each
set I feel like oh if I want something I
know I just need to race from there like
20 minutes and I'll get it so I don't
feel like I'm being like backed into a
corner at all but Gran Turismo 6 had
almost 1,200 cars in it some of them
were outdated models and stuff like that
whatever this game only has like just
over a hundred which doesn't sound so
bad except when you consider that like
Mesa a Mitsubishi it's their cars it's
like four versions of the Lancer and
that's four out of the hundred some-odd
right right so it's like you start
losing the demo
yes that's totally yeah from everything
I've read if I'm wrong shoot me down but
I'm pretty sure that that is everything
I've read it outside of the demo and in
essence this feels like a prologue
experience and a prologue is they've
released a couple of them in the Gran
Turismo series they come before the main
game and it's sort of like look we want
to give you something we want to show
you what's coming here you go but this
is not called prologue this is called GT
sport so there's that sort of misnomer
but the other thing involved is that I
know right what I know 1972 Steve
Buscemi it was so the other thing that
sort of hampers this game is that it's
always online and that is because it's
tied into an FIA sponsored ranked
supported racing championship series
like so this game is being removed from
the casual racing fan audience in a
sense and being tailored for
I want to be a professional racecar
driver on the Internet I want to enter a
championship that when I win I'm
recognized by a national body and it's
super important so everything has to you
you can barely play this game if you're
not online because the FIA is regulating
how you know who has what car is how the
currency has managed all of this
everything is tracked by this this
racing body which is like okay very
interesting but why can't I opt out of
that if I if I never in my life want to
be involved at that [ __ ] which I
personally do not why do I have to
succumb to those limitations that for me
is a little bit of a problem and that is
indicative of why Gran Turismo is always
sort of this this game that exists on
the fringe where the hardcore people can
really get into it even if it's not
perfect and other people can still
appreciate it like me but there's always
like something that keeps it at least in
the past few games that keeps it just
out of reach from being like truly
awesome and so far I'm not feeling that
this is a truly awesome game I feel like
it has the potential but it's being held
back in a number of ways I know
obviously I haven't played even half of
what's available because it's a big demo
for sure but it doesn't have everything
I can play all the modes but not on the
maps not all the the trials and the
learning tutorials none of that some of
that not all of it but I do feel like
this game has a a problem a fundamental
foundational issue in that it's tied in
to the FIA in a circuit thing and again
I have to point back to the Cosmo
Yamaguchi for that because I think that
it's his his personal preferences are
being are driving this do you think in
the I mean the modern landscape of
racing games you 4 to 7 and then Forza
horizon 3 last year what else you have
like you said Need for Speed more
arcadey but do you think GT is still
relevant or is that I think FIA thing
their attempt to do something different
well it's definitely attempt to do
something different I think it's very
much still relevant because people are
so excited for this series which means
that it's relevant but I think that this
game will hurt the long-term relevance
of Gran Turismo a series that's been
hurting in its last few entries I don't
think it'll ever get back to where it
was like for was incredible game that I
remember with you know la with great
fondness and v was really great too on
ps3 although it came out a bit too early
for that
generational leap I think was a spec
three yeah that was my first ps2 game
ever I'm pretty sure that was three yeah
yeah it's it's it's a it's a quirky
racing series that you know you have to
appreciate some of the strange things
that like they work with car
manufacturers to get concept cars built
just for this game I'm like designed by
Honda you don't even like or whatever
manufacturer you're talking about and
that's pretty cool but no longer can I
go and buy the weird junker or like the
old silly car like I used to I used to
be able to used to be able any car
almost any car you get thinking you
could say wow they have that car in
there that's 76 Alfa Romeo whatever sure
I can get that that VW from 1990 Wow
well you know they have it to hear like
the quirkiest thing I've seen is a VW
bus and that's one of like maybe six
Volkswagens in this games it's it's a
bit disheartening as someone who's
always loved the idea that okay I know
if I was super passionate and like a
hyper diligent racing fan that I could
get that out of Gran Turismo but I don't
need to be that to enjoy it I could
enjoy it on many levels yeah that
doesn't exist anymore as far as I can
tell
seems almost like they're they're super
encouraging that more high-level
professional kind of play as opposed to
just letting you play how you want it
which sounds like that was one of the
appeal of the series to you yeah and
then there is still some accessibility
so within you know the the stuff that I
can play with in this game I can adjust
it so it actually feels the way I want
it to feel so if I still enjoy playing
it but I don't know if it has the
long-term appeal for me it's the sort of
thing where you know I'm going back and
forth playing this and forth and trying
to get a feel for like ok where does
each one fall and they they feel very
different but but right now I'm leaning
towards you know if I had to pick one
racing game I would currently pick four
to seven out of those two I still have
to play more Gran Turismo so will see it
has VR I haven't really tried that and
great setting yet that could be really
cool I haven't tried it with a you know
wheel and stuff so we'll see maybe
there's something extra there for
PlayStation VR owners to get excited
about but as of yet I'm a little worried
so GT sport releases
next week on Tuesday on Tuesday that'll
be the
17th yes yeah it's for PlayStation 4 you
know we have anything up on the site
like gameplay-wise you know we're just
gonna wait until the review comes oh
it's gonna wait til the review cool I
guess that's as good a transition as any
to main conversation today which
everybody on the YouTube chat at least
is clamoring for four to seven what does
clamoring look like uh like people come
on give it to me yeah that's exactly
what you do okay I don't know I thinking
clam but that's a lobster that's a crab
your hands are individual clams four
seven you know and there were loot crate
concerns Star Wars Battlefront 2 beta
was live late last week in - what -
yesterday or today yesterday today as of
9:00 a.m. Pacific loot crate's were a
concern and then of course shadow for
much of the conversation
unfortunately surrounding that since
they announced them back in the summer
is was the loot crate's goodbye orcs you
can buy equipment a lot of us have
played more shadow of war I haven't
they're definitely lingering there
Justin hey will puts it much more
eloquently and you can go more in depth
with his review but they're definitely
there but they don't seem to matter that
much
no as opposed to Battlefront - which is
huge kind of concern of Rob's I know
you've been playing a lot of that a lot
of people yeah I mean my my concern you
know we had the two days early access
people who pre-ordered so within my
first eight hours of playing a beta was
a major concern there's a lot to talk
about with this stuff so for those of
you who don't know how this system works
and well this is again speaking on the
beta right we do not know necessarily
what the final product is gonna look
like however but this you're willing to
bet that this is pretty much like they
showed this off like what six months ago
as well yeah right we talked about this
before yeah so like what's gonna change
or basically like you know balancing and
what what comes in a crate but this
isn't grain into the gameplay this is
how it works this is how you progress in
this game is by opening crates
how it works is there are different
rarities associated with crates excuse
me just star cards or you get out of
them we have we do not know and that's
another thing they'll talk about later
we do not know what these crates what
other forms they'll take like I've heard
rumors that there are crates specific to
classes so there are four classes if I
want you know if I want to focus on a
specialist class I can get the
specialist crate and be guaranteed one
star card as of the beta now yeah you
get three in each one different levels
of rarity like uncommon common epic
Legendary's Legendary's this is the
kicker legendary star cards you can only
get in a loot crate there's another way
you can progress more or less is with
sorry is with crafting parts crafting
parts i can get from luke rates or i can
get them through career which is on the
top menus their career is basically like
your challenges for it's like kill 250
enemies in a Glac to conquest map and
get 20 credits points the then my first
frustration when I was playing after
eight hours was that I had 880 crafting
points I said to my I set a goal and as
far as the crushing my progression I was
like you know what I like the specialist
class I want to put a scope on the rifle
of this weapon well I was still unable
to do that because that crafting part
costs 100 crafting parts eight hours in
I was unable to do my own my own
challenge you know what I mean like my
own form of lighting a scope on a gun
putting out a goddamn scope on it that's
gone I was not able to do that within
eight hours hour one like this is not
like outrageous and this time it and
this is yeah and this is one scope on
one gun for a class like that that made
like Peter I remember texted you late at
night I was really frustrated with that
because what is happening is you're
getting credits from
after matches which are not actually
dependent on your skill so if someone
kicks ass if someone plays like garbage
you're for the most part getting the
same amount of credits but you're
opening crates man you're opening fairly
often and what you getting in these
crates well as of the beta you're
getting like so many times I was getting
freaking emotes for like Ray or Boba
Fett dude I can't I've never been both
once and then the game ended like it's
it's just most of time you're just
getting [ __ ] there was one time I'm
sorry because it just didn't give you
what it promised it that was one exact
you took the words on my mouth one time
I was like cuz I there I will say a lot
of things with this beta just the the
Starfighter mode is frickin awesome
either like I just this morning I played
some more of it before it ended I like I
really liked that mode I really do
yet there is a Starfighter crate I open
that up guess what I was supposed to be
guaranteed didn't get a single
Starfighter card it was like these
things she was just copies it was like
nothing that it was promised granted
that's beta but that's annoying I'm
annoyed if if like if I have to live
there are two ways for me to progress
right either I luck out with the loot
crate or I use crafting parts and said
loot crate didn't even offer what it
what it said in the beta and will point
you to spend money what that's dude
that's the foot that's the [ __ ]
question because here's the thing I will
lose my mind and I guarantee it I will I
will lose my goddamn I'm are already
losing it if there are legendary blue
crates guarantee legendary Luke racer
which I think there will be that is
that's messed up that is them that is
the most aggressive like mobile game in
the crate system I've ever heard
apologies if you've said this already
but didn't don't you say when people
kill you it shows what they had equipped
so damn right so like hey why would they
do that that's just gonna make you feel
like we forget more cards right and then
yeah that's the thing like they're just
trying to like lure you into it like
that guy just killed you with this
ability so why not go by
and it's there're so many things that
are racing from through my head that one
night where I was fresh I was like you
know I'm thinking about it's Star Wars
right think about the the audience that
that franchise has just locked there our
guarantee going to be twelve year old
kids who have maybe access to their
parents card who you know it's just it
is all right you four crush when you
open one those things up and you get
something sick I did happen to me I was
like sick my bomber my bombers health
now is like real great where his like
damage output is really awesome now like
that's a rush and you're you're
consistently doing that [ __ ] and you
have to you have to that's another thing
I hope they fix is you like you can't do
that in between rounds I have to legit
leave the the game and go into this damn
menu open it up
put it on like upgrade if I want I don't
know it's just like similar issues of
destiny I have yeah that's and that's so
minor to grand scheme of what we're
really talking about but I just think
about that like if this game is is going
to be throwing loot crate's so often for
forum practically an impressionable like
kid like that's that's scary to me
that's like the thing is again it's when
I say legendary creates its because if
they do that and they're like guaranteed
one legendary card dude think about that
mindset that's again oh that's great how
often do I do I get legend eight cards
well I can only get it like that's what
you're that's the endgame right does you
want legendary cards on all your [ __ ]
that you like meaning you have to own
the only we can get one is if I open up
a crate like if they are guaranteeing
one with I'm not saying they are doing
this but that's what's gonna set me over
it's like screw that I don't want to
have to like keep thinking about that
and and get killed by a guy with three
legendary cards on like day two in the
bottom line issue is that this just
supersedes the game its itself it sounds
like this is this is the thing that
stands out to you this may to win is
Peter win and the fact that the
something the gameplay isn't good enough
but it's that
ei is focusing much more on this system
than actually just providing a good game
to people it's manipulation the gambling
part is a game right the gambling part
is the game well you guys yeah because
that's a bunch of people YouTube chatter
saying why don't they just file a
complaint saying it's gambling as of so
Jason Schreyer over at Kotaku today at
noon was that today
he spokes the ESRB and they say they
don't see loot boxes his gambling
they said the statement reads ESRB does
not consider loot boxes to be gambling
they told Kotaku while there's an
element of chance in these mechanics the
player is always italics guaranteed to
receive in-game content parentheses even
if the player unfortunately received
something they don't want a lot of
duplicates or something that they didn't
know they were gonna get maybe like a
skin they didn't want or a gun they
wanted ability they want we think of it
as a similar principle tickle
collectible card games like Pokemon
sometimes you local if I open a pack and
get a brand new holographic card you've
had your eye on for a while but other
times you'll end up with a pack of cards
you already have so it's not gambling
because you're unlike a slot machine
you're always guaranteed to get
something but you do know when you're
buying a pack of cards the chances of
finding something rare yeah I think in
situations like this they should at
least give stats like you will get a
legendary 50 boxes right you have a 1 in
20 chance something like that what I can
because at what point is it what point
does it go from undesirable outcome but
not gambling to a loss because it feels
like the difference between gambling and
loot boxes according to this definition
is that you have a net gain according to
your definition but like I do play games
the dupe is not getting to a player
correct so like at what point does from
a business standpoint you still got a
product yeah exactly so like at what
point does it does it bridge the gap I
mean like I think you're right in that
if they provided some sort of like
percentage or statistic to say like
here's the likelihood of getting
something out of the spot you would know
then you wouldn't have to sit there he'd
be an informed gambler sure
yeah but like I know that idea like of
you sort of get like overwhelmed with
the the hope it like maybe I'll get
something right like I sitting Lee found
myself
last Saturday bored after playing
destiny for a few hours not getting what
I wanted that I actually paid money to
get some silver to buy something from
never versus yeah I did that one I did
that I got [ __ ] and I was like whoa what
what came over me like and then I was
thinking the flip side like and if I had
gotten something would that have just
reinforced the behavior for me and what
am I actually getting do I actually care
about this do I even care about destiny
I thought it robs the game of its own
identity and your your relationship to
it again like I I kind of think that
what they were doing with this beta was
just to test the waters with like
balancing in that respect meaning like
because I'm again like it's it's again
what you're getting in these crates
right like like I can't tell you the
amount of times I got I got a goddamn
stormtrooper pose from this to like this
like two of those in there to begin with
I know shirt shows how they're diluting
it right donor stand things or they're
purposely trying to screw us and and
here's nothing to is that like we're I
mean they turn let this function off
which is weird to me because I would
like to see how that system works is
getting dupes
I got dupes probably six times but I was
not able to as they had said to convert
them into crafting parts hmm
because again like a big part of that
frustration that I was having was that
like I wasn't getting enough crafting
part right it was that was taking way
too slow that I need that will be
balanced I would imagine that they're
gonna like dial back a little bit and
make things more constructive again with
like more classifications of like a star
fighter you know
bomber crate that's more specific like
they'll have maybe more of those to like
ease that like people complain about
progression but but it sucks that that
is the fulcrum for whether or not you
like this game is how right they decide
to be a [ __ ] right and after the game
comes out and if it doesn't sell that
they can then range it that that's
[ __ ]
it is farms been jank on our YouTube
chat would just brought up a good point
in China Blizzard had to start
disclosing loot crate probability drops
which those are all
setec that's nothing like battlefront 2
which is abilities and everything China
means right china was saying that it's
because of gambling laws they had to
disclose drop pub probabilities and if
the ESRB were to classify
microtransactions as gambling these
publishers or develop publishers would
have to make these games adults-only
which would cut out all of their sales
because you can't sell it to only games
and retail stores from well in like Game
Stop and Best Buy at Target they would
lose all their sales hence they would
get rid of micro trains they could also
just put in a progression model that is
clear to the player that doesn't revolve
around random jobs and just sell you the
[ __ ] you want for the money that you're
gonna pay for it upfront like you don't
have to have this sort of like vague
intermediary word it must be just random
thing
let me progress and if that's not fast
enough for me sure I'll throw you money
if I really want to I want to be that
guy just strip out the randomness of it
the randomness is the problem it's fine
a lot of free-to-play game right because
this is where this all started I would
say it back with like mobile games
became big free play but that's but that
time is money man like right I don't
know that it's okay no no but back with
free to place feel like they're taking
that model which pretty much you just
have the choice to spend more time to
unlock these things or spend money which
that plays off of your the time you want
to spend whereas these games were paying
$60 already right that's obviously yes
it goes without saying that's the huge
problem with it but then it becomes a
problem because so I was looking I was
curious because I know with mobile games
the free-to-play games make most of
their money off like I select few whales
yeah people who spend a ton of money
whereas most people won't spend anything
according to statistics so I was curious
about how much money micro transactions
actually make and I didn't find a lot of
figures because my in my head I was like
at what point is the bad press gonna
deter publishers from even implementing
these because I don't want to sound
sappy but my heart does break for
developers like I have to assume
monolith was not super on board with
these micro transactions yeah
multiplayer the people at those making
months but I have to imagine it wasn't
their decision it must have come down
from yeah you put
sign of the game the maps and stuff you
can the legacy is exactly so to clarify
before to seven they changed their like
how you were in credits it used to be
you could spend like X dollars a year to
be part of the premium Club which he
would get plus 100 percent credits
earned all the time now you get twenty
five like burner cards to do that
essentially if you pay that premium
price also you used to be able to like
change around your mods they're called
mods like you would you could drive at
night for extra credits right now those
are also burner cards you get randomly
so one day you'll get like drive at
night for extra credits the next day
you'll get like drive this specific
course or in it's all random so then you
can't like you don't know what you're
gonna have to do to get the money it's
not clear it's not transparent it's not
like people paying the premium price
whereas they used to just have a set
plus 100% experienced credit bonus now
it's 25 one-time use cards my question
and a lot of people are at what point
are a or Warner Brothers or Microsoft
gonna start saying the bad press isn't
worth it because this is a great game
without it so I looked up like the price
point that these microtransactions make
and you the biggest figure I found as of
last fall and November I believe was I
want to ask you guys you might see it
right now sorry no no it's fine ultimate
team across FIFA Madden and NHL the last
year's titles how much do you think
something being the main
microtransaction focal point where
people can pay for certain players and
increase their team you don't have to
pay but it again expedites the process
in a game you already paid $60 for how
much do you think those three games made
for EA and microtransactions Cali
ballpark I'm so bad at this no you're
fine it's curious like what other
people's perception is the whole year I
made about like 2.3 billion in turn like
all like revenue last year how much of
that was ultimate team micro transaction
purchases three hundred thousand okay do
you see it okay but yes but I have a
follow-up question okay
guess how much Activision made last year
wait hold on let me tell ya so you said
three hundred thousand six hundred fifty
million
what altima team along that's not
counting so now he is putting this stuff
on battlefront to people look that much
money into that and again I don't like
they not many people disclose
not many people disclose their their
figures but as of last year that's what
AI said on an earnings call CEO
Jorgenson that last name
Jurgens okay no no 650 million is
ultimate team specifically ultimate team
might recruit microtransactions that's
not counting any number of other ways
you can spend money through to EA
to give EA and microtransactions alright
Activision what games like what just a
wizard blizzard stuff wizard called duty
duty Skylanders sure what do they mean I
don't know if Skyler's counts as
microtransactions people are buying the
toys as part of that platform building a
solid bill you got I would say 1 billion
and $1 mmm I'll do a billion - is over
three point six billion dollars oh ok so
a lot of that like I can see that I
guess now that I think about it like
Blizzard like I've been tempted to buy
crates before did Mass Effect Andromeda
have these because that's like an early
example I can think of Mass Effect 3 had
random loot crate's but the difference
being there although it might have
sparked this kind of unfortunate trend
that was a co-op mode in Mass Effect 3
so it wasn't like battlefront 2 where
you're playing against other people who
could be spending money or maybe not
that was co-op mode so if someone else
spent more money they're still on your
team fighting off these aliens with you
so that wasn't such a problem and I
actually probably spent maybe like 50
bucks getting those because that was the
first instance that and I think that's
the last time I've ever spent have you
guys do you actually I'm curious like
I'm not gonna shame you but have you
spent money on micro transactions ever
before yeah I have before I ever watch
in Mass Effect 3 for me over watch like
for specific I was trying to get like
Halloween and Christmas constabie
costumes to be completely honest I I
will do it just to see like I'm sorry I
will do it once like destiny was example
was like I just want to see what it is
volatile I don't know
I don't know I like to think it's like
part of or in my mind in my mind I'm
like it's part of the job like I just
want to know like what I'm getting into
well I mean I justify it because we got
the game for free and it's like well I
didn't yeah that's another thing is like
the money I spend on games is part far
different than like the average person
who spends money on games which is why I
have no concept of how much people like
the fraction of their total profits for
like whatever Altima team also I don't
care out sports with her that is just
like I'm still reeling about that that's
so much money I mean and that's yeah
that's not even considering what they
had Battlefield one last year as well
hey I know like the fraction of their
total profits from all of those games
this was just Ultimate Team one mode
across three years oh my god six billion
dollars that's more revenue than EA head
[Laughter]
Grand Theft Auto oh sure I mean that's a
huge one yeah hundred dollars right but
start car but that's it's been over five
years but those aren't random eyes you
know what you're getting right or do you
I'm actually asking you're legit putting
money into a different currency to buy
like new vehicles new vehicles
literally everything but you have you
have the choice over what you're
actually putting the money toward right
on GTA I'm there with you I'm sure that
makes a ton of money it's I mean it's
you heard about their earnings and why
like it's like you know someone looked
at like a release window for for
Rockstar Games right right for his been
a while since I've made a game or as
much like crazy money as GTA 5 made they
don't need to make another thought for
how long GTA online I'm sure Red Dead
Redemption 2 will have that gangs and
robbers here's a random Hortis pray be
careful there's quicksand like you'll
get chickens first I do want to say that
that is a less egregious model then the
buying a random drop yeah thing and
destiny in the ever verse case for
destiny like you can still get a bright
and gram through play yeah sure so like
I don't have a problem with it's like
it's so tied to the progression right
it's like I wanted to just go back on
that yeah but I will say that I the like
I spend I've spent money on mobile games
where like it's the same thing where
you're buying a separate currency but
you know what you're putting that money
into right like Fire Emblem heroes or I
was really gonna ghost like Sailor Moon
match 3 or I spent money but like the
most egregious example was that I think
it was the game that like set set off
like the up the uproar for the App Store
for iOS was the kid who was playing like
a totally heavy-handed like this is a
children's game and he was able to like
in the game was a button was like buy
more coins
yeah [ __ ] my mom was like what how did
you do that so easily I showed my mom
candy crush like a while back like when
it first came out and she got really
into it and I want really likes those
kinds of games and she spent like I
think ten dollars on the game or
something and my dad was so mad he was
like this is so stupid why'd you do this
and she was like you spent $60 on a new
Call of Duty every year so I can spend
$10 on candy Christmas man I was like
Kathy Kathy okay that makes sense but I
mean like just going back to the the
difference between like spending money
on a currency where you can then buy the
thing that you are looking for
specifically versa and also that was a
game that was free to play so it's a
little a little different micro
transactions are like going to Taco Bell
with $10 giving it to them and saying I
hope I get a crunch Ravan and they just
give you a gordita crunch or something
exactly
YAG bullsháá that's the best bull ship
Hartman that's a great metaphor and then
on the comparison free you don't mind
going over that that cow over there and
begin the process of making yuan cheese
all this yourself there's a farm in the
back it's gonna take about four months
to grow the beans for reef wrap it's
freeze
if I went to talk about and they said
hey you can have a Crunchwrap you can
either make it yourself
or you can pay $3 and like that's fair
but if I give them five bucks and
they're like we don't know we're gonna
give you they just give me a six bag -
cinnamon - it's just my wanted to maybe
we can we could end it on this part of
this talk is Jesus I'm taking so long
said you were you brought up like yeah
yeah you you broke like the balancing
right of like okay now going back to
these crafting parts right
someone did I was going through a bunch
of like a threat threads of people like
tackling and complaining about this it
is it's a really disgusting system right
now for this battlefront beta some
didn't matter was like okay if every
loot crate you got like 15 crafting
parts by chance which that doesn't even
happen like it's but if it were the case
if it were guarantees and you wanted to
buy and upgrade every gun in battlefront
which is two weapons just to just in the
beta yeah for each class like how long
do you think that would thing someone do
the math 300 hours it's like three
thousand hours three thousand hours to
not spend money on that game that's just
pretty sure that's a number that's just
for the beta so it's it's over a
thousand I know that much I swear oh god
it's ridiculous so the point the point
is there's no way that that as of the
beta like that balancing is gonna be in
play I cannot fathom that number that
rate of which you get crafting parts to
be the case but it's interesting and you
brought up Peter which is like I have I
just it's just a weird feeling I'm just
like they debate like the people they
are the puppet masters yes like they
went to like the gross spectrum of beta
and like I wonder if it was like
intentionally alright intentionally just
like stirred all this all this like
frustrate this frustration in like heat
yeah just so in the gross just so that
the the changes that are made are like
so significant oh good job you know what
if you don't getting out
it's like like they it's like they
wanted to see the reaction and what if
there wasn't what if there wasn't any
reaction sure and they're like oh damn
we don't know they made me keep it the
way it is they mate they might do that
they might do that oh the grotto
I bet term of beta was kind of a
frustrating thing because I really I
think that's things we haven't talked
about the positive qualities of this
game like we did I did everything and
like Mike brought that up like I feel so
bad for the people because like you can
criticize a developer or a publisher but
like the individual people who put in
work I always feel for those people and
it just sucks yeah like it's it's it's
pretty fun to play but like these things
are just so looming battlefront 2 seems
fun at its most basic level
well maybe not most basic level but
apart from the microtransactions like a
Courtney Harborview and a bunch of you
around the office and the Internet in
general shadow of war is a very fun game
it's it's ambitious as hell and I do
feel bad that I'm sure monolith can't
talk because if they hey I'm sure
they're contractually obligated they
can't say anything about Warner Bros
again this is all just assumptions
assuming Warner Bros push down this
dictum on them contractually also they
can't really bite the hand that feeds as
the publisher so it sucks but you know
they were they were adamant about saying
they went through the game to make sure
it's perfectly balanced without loot
crate's and then that always begs the
question like so doesn't adding the
crates imbalance it or I don't know like
it just perturbs something that was it
was serene right yeah it's like front of
rocking upon it up so Dave on twitter
twitter name is Dave but his handle is
the upshot Canada
he says ESRB says loot boxes aren't
gambling what do you what say you I
would say like I think as maybe to an
outside business sense in the
traditional sense it's not gambling but
then like two people who spent a lot of
money and no mentally monetarily for
people who are playing games regularly
or even just playing you play destiny to
all year it's still gonna be gambling if
you're doing that reverse stuff but I
mean I would be interested to see the
the physiological response
like a comparison between getting a loot
crate or you know getting like a drop
that you worked for in destiny and like
just gambling and I guess you know I
would love to see I'm sure they've done
Studies on this I know they they had in
the past with like this the reactions
people get from from really addictive
games I had a friend who told me
something about like The Sims when I was
like oh the Sims makes you feel like
you're on cocaine addicting to describe
anything about a video gaming review
because it sends this weird message
first of all addicting is a stupid word
and you should say addictive but also
it's not a good descriptor I mean I
would be really interested to see the
similarities but I mean just from my gut
instinctive gambling I there's I didn't
know if I ever like explained also like
how these star cards work and feel like
again these are damage boosters
increased health like it would when I
when I was playing on the stream I'd
been using a wing a lot earlier and I
was like I like I thing like the other
one better about fighter and then on
stream I was like damn hey leagues like
I'm rocking right now it's fast nimble
but like firepower I'm taking on guys oh
wait
and that's because and I have to train I
let I looked at the start cards I was
like oh that's interesting because I
forgot I put on two star cards that were
like epic one was longer longer cooldown
I don't I was short no she's not shorter
cooldown overheating increased time
before over magazine yes in like like a
double fire rate and yeah and I took
then I took them off and like notice
that like yeah oh yeah this is harder to
like yeah take down guys and now there's
another factor to where it's like yeah I
also have to level up these these ranks
in order to like unlock the ability to
put a star card on
that I still haven't gotten my third one
and I put 15 hours into the game already
I haven't gone my third ability to put a
star card on an a wing yeah and I like
like you said at the beginning I like
that you were trying to be optimistic
but I don't think this is gonna change
before November this kind of system that
sucks because this game no you know
streams that we would want it to be yeah
like it's it's intricate it's integral
now to like their whole system like with
that getting cards and that's where all
these abilities are dude you soon it's
just gonna be this thing right this is
gonna be another sitting setting off
point where it's like hi if I die and I
see okay a TIE fighter fly by
you know I kill cam and it says Oh what
did he have and I just started the game
that's high that TIE fighter just had a
lights his wings are made out of
lightsabers Lloyd Christmas constant
friend of the show on Twitter said to
the panel what is your limit with loot
boxes I would say battlefront - no front
- yeah I guess I don't like him in
general and sometimes you put up with
them as necessary and necessary evil
yeah I don't yeah my limit is when it
feels like it's it's taking control of
the game out of your hands yeah yeah
look at Horry like you said earlier when
it's cosmetic it's that can be fun like
unlocking a skin and overwatch um
because then you have like a side thing
to work for I think that can be fun yeah
and cosmetic for sure
yeah that's it we are kind of going
along but I do want to end on a positive
note I mentioned shadow war I've been
playing a lot more but I really like the
game it's it's it's it is annoying to
see this kind of stuff when you go into
the market and I've been going to the
market briefly to spend what's the
currency it filled in I think on like
crates for weapons when I have not gone
to the point where I'm I could be
actually no I did pay for a crate that
gave me orcs for to be followers or you
know they are slaves don't really want
to talk about it in that game box and
some living things come out of it
it's yes sir what you want you
essentially don't you don't have to
touch though through the game the game
is fantastic the Nemesis system is great
the I love running into people it's so
much more this game is so much quirkier
and almost like whimsical because I run
into these certain it's such got a
self-aware humor I ran into uh
everything was gruff to poet and I wish
I remembered the rhyme but he he
essentially when he they introduced him
he's like Ryan jaw and the he's I forgot
but you you were on today you can give
that a double and it's great and I also
ran into one guy showed you and
sometimes there are monologues if you're
watching this right now you can see they
do these monologues kind of threats just
pumping themselves up for the fight
there's one dude not that sexual okay
that's right God not to plug our own
stuff but this is actually a pretty cool
video we did like all but within the
first like 20 hours all the best
interest we had I I would recommend
watching this because I was laughing
tourists yeah keep going Sarah Mike no
II love every once awhile they'll just
be like growling and it'll be done
you'll fight next one will be this long
like monologue like tell that mean ocean
like screaming he talks for a long time
and then a couple of that was like if
there there's one in this video I was
like it's like what are we just gonna
fight yes like three it goes from one
word to another I didn't do that last
time I don't know what did do that I
guess but like one guy will have this
long a speech and then another orc will
come up and betray him just cut his that
whirling the sword and he shoots but
guys it's the writing in these moments
is so great because did you know
monolith it's almost like a Family Guy
joke you think he's done talking he goes
another
seconds and I'm by the time I'm laughing
I feel bad for killing him because he's
such an idiot but they also have knew
the tribes there's different tribes
there's feral there's dark it just kind
of influences how they attack you what
special attacks they have feral will
have like it also kind of subtly affects
their aesthetic there are more like
feral will wear animal bones like right
here he's probably oh no he's the dark
tribe but those guys is drunk yeah
and you can they don't have their own
weaknesses and certain things will
enrage them and it's awesome when you
fight too so one will be enraged when
you put them to really low health and
then he'll go into like berserk and then
another person will be terrified of
other orcs that are buzzer 'king so they
all start interlocking in great ways but
then there's also people that are
cheating death because they're like
tricksters that's their class dude this
guy he the the orc captain doesn't do
any of the like talking he's got like a
hype man yeah this game I really really
like this guy
yeah opinion aligns very closely with
Justin hey Walt who did our review and
it's again he said they were the they
were just like the microtransactions
were attacked on that was like just to
be the segue of from last segment but he
also said the Nemesis system is great in
this game it's you know the game does
feel a little bit bloated in the way it
tries to be destiny with its crate or
what sorry no its crates still stuck in
my head with its giggling with the way
you know you can break down things but
in the final act apparently yeah so it's
yeah you get to a certain point and they
kind of require you to grind for
fortress defense the sieges are great or
you could just read the ending in the
appendix apparently yeah well before
doing yeah and you kind of know where
this is all gonna lead this is the
between channel well this is before the
lore the rain starts it's yeah these
characters are they they are very
self-aware and how dumb they are and
it's great but the hype man's my
favorite I have to see more of that hi
man and I have an emotional poet wears a
beret and he's my
he's he's my current nemesis so when you
press when you just press the touchpad
it'll show your current assistant he's
always there with his beret on he looks
like this like he lives in the West
Village and he's also always just
writing shitty poetry and he does this
is the dude right here this just flogged
the one that I with the long monologue I
should give this a joke this him so if
you're watching it just one word pay
attention to how long he talks at this
point I'm already dying laughing he's
still going arm gestures like what the
[ __ ] when are we gonna fight and then
Yeah right there finally he starts and
it's not Oh on the contrary
he smoked me this no he's a party you
should you should play shadow for if
shadow Mordor piqued your interest with
its Nemesis system which it should have
is a great design innovations actually
pretty simple but great use of it you
find your own story in this game I know
Lucy James is talking about some enemies
she had that just sound hilarious play
the game a monolith did a fantastic job
with it and again you can read our view
Justin was really positive on the game
it just it's unfortunate that it got
roped into the microtransaction
conversation with forces 7 Battlefront 2
but that game is fantastic monolith did
a great job Michael de plater and his
team we actually did a we did a video on
how tough it can be to bring Loring's
licensed games in general but also Lord
the Rings specifically to video games it
has a long and spotty history John Luke
did his history of Lord the Rings games
gonna get more into that the Third Age
is better than anyone will ever tell you
don't let them tell you it's a bad game
what are you gonna say oh wait too long
but it's this why do you think that work
system could have gone completely like
wrong yeah
it could have been so annoying like they
like have no
gotta own it so flogged I he cheated
death so he's alive still after I killed
him and I'm just waiting to see him like
no and he's gonna start his monologue
I'll just go grab a like a beer come
back finish the beer and then finally
fight him like okay do your things
coming an Apple box that he's dancing
microphone fights yeah shadow for a
fantastic game please go check it out if
you have the time money or if you're
interested in anything like Lord of the
Rings you know it's not the most
faithful or the Rings adaptation but
it's it's a fun game
any last-minute things would you got on
the docket this week Peter that's right
Gran Turismo sport you gonna try any
evil within - we're gonna talk a little
bit about evil within - in general I
will say we can talk about the first
seven chapters Jon loosen playing a ton
it's not first six chapters alessandro
is reviewing it for us they both have
very positive things to say especially
compared to the first game I would say I
love like I love two-thirds of the first
game hated the last third I'd loved 10
chapters 1 to 10 the last five or go off
the rails in a bad way on the rails
actually on one point
Ralph's shooter that's the horror recipe
those like sometimes you love the first
yeah axe and then the last act falls
apart that's yeah the pain if a horror
fan yep very positive thoughts so far
the reviews would be up soonish
I don't think there's an embargo
Bethesda was kinda or for the full game
there might be something but Bethesda
actually sent out the copies earlier
than a day before we are gonna be
playing South Park in the coming weeks
think that's what's on your schedule
tonight right Rob yeah I'm pretty
excited South Park does that whole I
really really like the last one yeah
it's like ever playing till 1 a.m. for
capture sake because I had to keep
playing and like just somehow the game
managed me to like pause and just laugh
we're so long like South Park parking
those guys my founders so I guess Justin
was mentioning during our meeting today
you explore someone's but in the first
game so I can't imagine where they're
gonna go with this one there are a whole
their whole intestines yeah usually go
body you travel up gross
love it Callie what are you up to
anyways
yeah I mean there is that whole episode
where it's just Oprah's vagina talking
anyway
Minjae what am i - I'm prepping for the
coming weeks the calm before the storm
so yeah I go home and I play stardew
valley until I can't stay awake anymore
that's the same with me I'll probably
play evil then - tonight
Peter send me a code that Bethesda was
nice enough to give us be trying that
out what else am I going shadow war star
to Valley a lot I'm saying all this to
sound like I'm doing my job well I'm
just gonna play star goo belly mmm cool
as always thank you everybody for
joining the twitch and YouTube chats and
on GameSpot thank you for sending
questions in before the show Lloyd
Christmas and Dave the upshot Canada I
appreciated questions led to some good
discussion we do have that giveaway it's
been going all week so far and there's
five winners a day you get to choose
whether you want the evil within two on
ps4 Xbox one or PC so Shiva should be
the twitch chat she might have already
put it in there but it's also up on
gamespot just go to the link that we'll
be tweeting out from GameSpot account
it's not one of those retweet things you
should go to the page and then on Friday
we'll be picking that would be the grand
prize day so two people will get these
PS this ps4 pro with evil then skin two
with Sebastian Castellanos on the front
or that Xbox 1s that's the grand prize
but you also the chance to win the game
itself which releases this Friday
October 13th so good luck with that you
can follow us on Twitter to get that
link to GameSpot and again that'll end
Friday when we hand out the grand prize
but it's going all week so get in on
that from everything that we've heard
that game is doing doing well it's good
the internet itself seems to be an
agreement with jean-luc and Alessandra
and Nick I think played a little bit
what I have nothing to say don't okay
cool
there's there's the Shiva and the twitch
chat right now but anyway thanks
everybody for joining thanks to John
Luke's IP Richard Lee and Eric Tay in
the back Thank You Callie Rob Peter
we'll be back next week 11:00 a.m.
Pacific Wednesday here in California I'm
Lottie we'll see you then
[Music]